I wish you a nice evening the second day
of python the pi data Berlin is already
almost over but the best part is just
ahead of us and these are the lightning
talks
yesterday it was long to today it will
be also we have at least one hour of
time uh we have plenty of submissions
well I don't remember them all but I
have a small sheet of paper where
some people noted them noticed them for
the me
and I have to appreciate actually how
what challenge you gave to me because it
well lighting tools are usually numbered
by integers but people were using
fractions and Float numbers irrational
numbers so I just had to sort them
accordingly somehow we have to do two
changes after yesterday lightning talks
usually take five minutes but if they
are announcements invitations to events
they are only two minutes
and
this we are going to do it 15 seconds
not 30 seconds before the end so you
don't have to clap so long time
now let's start with the number zero
that's
Katarina and Katarina liquid democracy
uh if how I would like everyone knows
who is going to give a lightning talk I
would like to ask you actually to move
nearby so we can start uh quickly and I
will always announce the next one after
that there will be Lisa with uh coral
Coral it so Katarina stage is yours
thank you okay yeah so as you
no clipping before lightning talk sorry
so we are both Katarina and we work for
liquid democracy ifo
and we want to use this talk to just
give you a short introduction into our
work there
so liquid democracy is a non-profit
Association we are based here in Berlin
and it was founded in 2009 and maybe as
a fun fact it actually evolved out of a
working group of the former pirate party
but yeah that's long ago and we are a
small team of 20 employees
um
with diverse backgrounds obviously
software development like two of us but
also people from social or politics
political sciences are working at liquid
democracy and we have a vision that is a
democratic culture in which active
participation is a given for everyone
because we believe that participation is
really important for a working Society
so with our work we try to make it
easier to both initiate participation
processes but also for people to take
part in them and how do we do that so
on the one hand we spread our knowledge
about participation and organize events
and workshops on that topic
but mainly we design and develop online
participation platforms
and also together with Partners from
Civil Society politics and
administrations we concept and Implement
participation processes and to give you
some examples for that so in 2020 we
built the platform on cat Battalion for
the German bundestag and that was a
participation process
where um citizens will ask for their
opinion about artificial intelligence
actually and the outcome of that
participation was then used by an
uncapped Commission on that topic for
their further work and another another
project we did was Civic Europe that was
an idea challenge
um where organizations from all over
Europe contend and ideas for projects
that needed funding and the community
could then vote for the winning ideas
that then actually won the funding and
last but not least we also develop and
maintain Mindy which is the
participation platform of the Berlin
Senate
um where the different
Berserker districts can initiate
participation processes so can be little
things like where would you think that a
new playground would make sense in your
area
um yeah so their citizens are really
included into decision making and now
um yes you might have guessed why we are
here it's because we built our Platforms
in Django
our code is open source and we use a
core Library called autocracy 4 to
Define the basic models and Concepts
that we use in these participation
processes
one of these models are the modules
where we have different ones you can
choose from and the idea challenge for
example is to collect ideas and then
prioritize them and the variant of that
was used for the um
Civic Euro platform for the uncapped
commission we use the debate module
which is to discuss topics that are
given and
for mind Berlin you the initiators can
actually choose any module they want to
use and can then fill in the information
for the
modules in this initiator backend
and the most important or interesting
information are the faces because they
have a start and an end date and they
determine what the user is actually
allowed to do during the participations
with the help of Django rules
um so
for the idea challenge for example we
first have a collect phase where the
users are allowed to create ideas and
comment on these and then rating phase
where the ideas can be rated
um and all our modules are combinations
of different phases with um different
words
um so for the user in the front and it
looks like this during collect phase
um so
um yeah the submitting ideas is allowed
so there's a button to submit ideas and
also the list where they can go on to
the detail page and then comment there
and that was already our tour through
what we do and yeah
thanks for listening
thank you very much Nick now comes
correled and Cornelius can prepare
um
I have not introduced myself I'm Miro
together with my wonderful colleague
Chuck
send that please
and in between we have prepared some
questions for you
so who is not for the first time at Pike
knows certainly when was the first
python de and where
who knows it
foreign you get one red point in
insignificant red point
yes
[Applause]
are we prepared okay another question
name all the cities where python e took
place until now
oh we just know one someone told us
before there's one already
no
so there was Leipzig now is Berlin and
in between there have been a few cities
who knows there's how many more like
Berlin lipstick and and how many more oh
there's one hand there
oh you know yeah like a frequent icon de
attendee so you must know organizer laps
if you lived move to cologne and then we
moved to Berlin there we had one in 2014
and then we moved to call sewer and then
move back to Berlin
thank you okay
again there's no price
[Applause]
this game
but yeah I've been to the coursework one
like I I really I really like it there
but it rings a lot I don't know I
remember that Sprint who who has been
there in 2018 who was there before yeah
you remember like we we go to that like
small place that have pizza like we go
to Sprint there remember yeah that was
that was that was very nice I want to I
want to have a Sprint again maybe one
day maybe yeah
can we start
so yeah here we are please five minutes
hello everyone and
and no clapping no clapping okay hello
everyone and thank you pie condata
Berlin for having me on stage to talk
about correlate
so please raise your hand if you have
heard of correlate before
okay I see some hands for those of you
who haven't let's change that
so correlate in a nutshell is a network
of over 2 400 people who team up with
non-profit organizations to support them
with data driven tools and now I will
tell you about some of the many things
we do in the natural in the correlate
community and how to get involved and
find out more about us
my name is Lisa and I have been an
active correlate Community for over five
years back in 2017 I joined the pro bono
project during my studies because I
wanted to gain more real world
experience outside of University and now
it's six years later I'm not in
University anymore but I'm still engaged
in the community
there's a lot going on next to the
project and I met some really good
friends along the way and correlate is
now my best source of memes and the
place where my nerd humor is understood
so corelight's Mission has three parts
and I will cover each of them briefly
the first one are the data for good
projects they are always Pro Bonos and
with a focus on applying and expanding
the volunteers Knowledge and Skills the
projects are usually in r or python but
there's also some web development and
software engineering projects it usually
depends on the needs of the non-profits
I brought you some examples to give you
a better idea of what we mean when we
talk about data for good projects so one
is the cargo bike project where the
volunteers improved cargo bike routing
by using images image data from local
streets
that was an open data project as well
and then there's the beekeeper project
but which was about anomaly detection in
beehives so that the beekeepers can
monitor their bees
um remotely
and those were two projects that
involved machine learning but not all
projects do some are also just data
analysis projects like the soup kitchen
project where time series analysis was
used to get a better understanding of
sales in a German soup kitchen and to
improve the meal planning and stocking
of the soup kitchen
what I personally like about the setup
of all the correlate projects is that we
always have a spot for a learner so that
even if you can be part of the project
even if you don't have the skills yet
but you are curious and want to learn
them
so back to the mission overview this was
just a small portion of over 60
completed projects since 2015.
now on to the education part of
correlate which involves empowering
non-profits by building up their data
skills and we have several offers for
non-profits one is a three-month online
learning program
uh so we we have a so-called under where
non-profits can book a slot with uh
calendly to get quick answers to their
questions and we also have a PR team who
run the correlate blog a podcast and our
social media accounts and share
information on topics relevant to
non-profits you should really check
check out their work I'm a huge fan of
how clean everything looks
um the last part I'm covering uh today
is the correlate Network so the main
aspect here is that next to the
decentralized projects we have local
chapters where you can find small
projects that grow out of the local
community and the local chapters usually
meet monthly and I would definitely
recommend checking them out if you are
curious
then there's a multitude of other
community internal happenings such as
our annual Coral con and annual meet up
a mentoring program a superb job sport
if you're interested
database code nights and I could go on
but now I want to extend the warm
welcome for all of you to join us if
some of what I just talked about sounds
interesting to you correlate is open for
all people who respect our code of
conduct and if you can't commit to a
project because it's too time intensive
there are many other ways to get in
touch for example locally or in the
um
in the internal workings so bring
yourself and don't be shy to bring your
own ideas as well
you can find us next week
thank you very much
now comes Cornelius with
Power Point
with python and then
are there any python C python core
developers here
one two
one two I see only two okay so if you
ask for three names that's probably too
few now but do people know their name
though ah okay so hide your name badges
that's that's very tricky or you can
name whoever that you know maybe you
follow them on Twitter maybe you follow
them on Instagram maybe you follow them
on Mastodon I don't know
yeah if you follow them on the street
that's creepy don't do that
um yeah so
but can you name free see python core
developer
yeah yeah yeah but you have already
answered so maybe other people can try
have you talked to them before in the
conference yes
yes maybe you can remember the name
no
oh you're starting
thank you okay so now we have uh
Cornelius we are five minutes and then
yep
all right so today I'm going to talk
about how you can automate your
PowerPoint in presentations with python
so first of all I have to say that I got
this data from my employer clinics week
who is sponsor of pycon it is all
Anonymous so nothing to worry about this
could be an example presentation for the
ticket sales of the pycon since 2017.
but since by now we have the new data
for 2023 you would have to update it and
since I'm not very sophisticated with
PowerPoint
I how I would do it is delete the slide
and add a new one with a new plot update
the number on the side here and so forth
and they can take really long and can be
really annoying when you have a lot of
slides with a lot of plots and numbers
but fortunately there is a solution the
pptx python package from that you have
to import the presentation module
until we have a little class where you
put in the template that you use for
your PowerPoint and the title of your
presentation and just like that you have
created a new PowerPoint presentation
this dictionary is not really necessary
but helpful because it lets you access
the ad layouts through their names
instead of an ideal number which is more
complicated
and now you could have this a function
like this for adding the slide where you
put in as a parameters the layout title
text and plot that you want to have on
the slide you get the layout through the
dictionary from before and at the new
slide right here you put in the layout
and now we have a couple more
dictionaries here it doesn't look pretty
I must admit but again it is helpful
because now you can access your
placeholders so the title the text and
the image through their names with this
dictionary instead of a number ID which
makes it way more easy and now you can
just say all right the text of my title
should be what I put in same for the
text
for the plot it is a little bit more
complicated you first have to save the
figure as as an image file and then you
can use the insert picture function
and then you're done with that and now
you could have a little presentation
function like this where you put in your
parameters and at the end you save the
presentation under any name that you
want
and that is it for the code I want to
show you and now I'm going to do a
little live demonstration I hope
everything works
so if we run this here
everything works good we have this
presentation that you saw earlier
already with the sales from 2017 to 2022
but now we have the new data so what we
do here is just change the data path and
the name that we want to save it under
to 2023
run it again
and as you can see a new presentation
just got created and as you can see we
have a new plot the number is updated
and presentation is done
thank you thank you very much
now comes Rima and next would be Jean
python search
and what question do we have now yes
skip that question because I know they
are presenting next to maybe people can
remember the name after they present so
skip that question which one the the
core Dev question
no about the integer
who can tell us what is the largest
integer that you can create in Python
what is the largest integer you can
create in Python yeah there is one
behind view trick yes hi oh okay
what's the number
if I remember my cryptocurs correctly
it's unlimited so you can just go
it's not it's unlimited it's not
Infinity I think we maybe we have to
like Define the question a little bit
better or something how would you write
it the largest number
well you have to write your code and I
ask you to create a large number so how
would you create the largest number
give us a hint give us a hint
I'm not sure we're talking about the
same thing
hahaha
this is the largest number that you can
create in python or the largest static
the largest integer number
is well it could be infinite but
okay so I I just expected that someone
maybe would give us some very large
number but who want to give it a try
this another one other reason someone
wants to give us a larger number yes
to the
64.
okay you won the prize
visual
okay we are prepared
here we are
so talk together a bit about packaging
and building for science so we have some
more effort we have libraries and we
want to exchange them easily
and yeah and this was a starting slide
and because the voice joins me I will
change a bit
and I hand over for him so you will see
all of these parts a little bit inside
and now
cool
yeah I was really lucky that I got a one
minute spot from Raima so it's a
lightning talk and a lightning talk and
so we've been working on some new
Tooling in the corner space which is
written and rust and I asked mid
churning to generate an image with a
crab and a snake
but it didn't really come up with
anything useful
I tried again with the rust logo and the
conda logo next to each other but
again pretty weird but the condo logo
kind of is there
anyways
we have been building at prefix.dev
we've been building a new library that's
called retla which is actually a bunch
of modular crates that are written in
Rust and there are really low level
libraries to read modify and solve for
condo packages
and we'll have python binding soon
and we have also worked for the past
three or four weeks on a new tool called
retla build which is a fast and
revolutionary way of building conduct
packages it's much nicer in my opinion
uh than condable today so if anybody of
you has experienced Corner build then
hopefully red lab build would make your
life easier
um and well we've implemented one recipe
format and now we're kind of thinking
maybe we can model it even more after
GitHub actions so that will be an
interesting development if anybody is
interested in joining these developments
then feel free to yeah look this up
and then I also wanted to make a really
brief pitch for prefix or death which is
a really nice website to look at Connor
Fortune bioconda now I'll hand back
yeah
um oh it's not on the screen completely
but so
no idea they have a problem with this QR
code but that's not a thing this shows
uh anaconda.org and this if you remember
back in 2012 the python Community has a
great year because at this time the
someone had the right idea to make
deployment building much easier for
anyone and there was an Arcana created
in the same year we also have
of the birth of num focus and had the
first Pi data conference in New York and
also for whatever reason this was a
global event or the pricing software
from
faband was founded
so when this was a big thing and you see
here what happens
we have now 30 as Millions users using
conduct packages of Anaconda
and they are from several regions and
there are a lot of downloads and these
downloads it also create costs so if you
are in a company which are for profit
you can give some money back to Anaconda
and Anna Corner itself can then also
serve the open source Community with
other repositories like the corner
Fortune pository This has about
257 million downloads monthly so this it
means Network traffic and if you have a
company and you are able to pay for
Anaconda that do this because this helps
the open source Community to serve
second approach Repository and this is
also uh has also is also backed up by
companies who have the call devs for
this and it helps with Stage Gypsy piece
and yeah you see it's a lot of effort
for open source stuff which can be used
from anyone for just sharing code and
getting on all platforms the packages
for that code
um this picture is from today in the
morning if you look at now at this QR
code it may be different because all
times people upload packages update
packages are also done by Bots automated
this is all the community effort of
GitHub actions Bots that they're running
and this helps us to keep all the things
done
and important is here also the member
org uh we
thank you very much
next one is Jean okay
yeah then comes Amsterdam
so the next question
is
depths or spaces
type of spaces how about how about
people who think
um people who think tabs clap your hands
people who think spaces clap your hands
do we have an answer for this question
actually oh that's great oh how many
spaces oh how many spaces okay
how many how many oh some someone
clapped four times is it four
seven who's that seven
someone put up their hand at the back
can you show all the magic number no no
you don't want to no no it's not okay
someone's shell 42 I think 42 you will
like me the whole code will be spaces I
don't know whether you want that to be
like it will be very long but anyway are
you still setting up okay when we are
already clapping maximal line length oh
yeah line length check is going to count
the clips
or you can like come out and like do
push-ups with how many linings
oh so it's kind of like a voting thing
right like how many okay how many things
the maximum line length is 108.
no
how many things like 90
okay okay okay okay how many thing is
I forgot the answer
yeah like um so so so what what do you
say
that's
[Music]
let's have a little uh vote in here so
who thinks it's more than it should be
more than 70.
[Applause]
keeps happen if not
it's more than 90. more than 90.
more than hundreds
more than 110
more than 120.
okay
for them because now you can get a very
long like curvy monitor so maybe that's
why
we got those one of those monitor
actually let me know wow
lucky you because I only have a laptop
okay are you ready yep let's go
five minutes hello is it working can you
hear me
yes awesome so yeah in the title of my
name was uh only there but we I'm doing
my name is John I'm doing together with
my brother-in-law and Earth
yeah hello I'm anias
so let's let's get started
um
so python search we want to talk about
open source project that we are working
together uh
and let's go talk about it the first
thing about it what is it and so it's an
open source assistant with a search
engine in it optimize it for Automation
and it's 100 in Python
even like the the data is in Python
rather than like normal documents as you
might think about search engineers uh
it's very efficient for collecting and
retrieving information and it goes
beyond retrieving information you can
also interpret information you can also
refactor because everything is in Python
with that said and as we'll oh
one thing more so this is how the UI
looks when you are collecting some
information let's say you get a URL and
then it gets converted into git which
turns out becomes Python and so each one
of these entries of the search engine
they are basically a string key and a
value that is a python dictionary which
is very extensible with all the power of
python with that said we're gonna show
you a demo that nesb walk us through
yeah
um in this demo I just copy the command
in this case h-top with some list
attached to it and I opened the UI I
gave it a descriptive name HD process
manager with delay and monochrome color
set it to CMD tested it quickly that it
works and there it is already if we now
look at the oh at the python file here
in the end we can see the entry itself
foreign
so this is the main search UI here we
don't use a graphical UI but rather a
fzf kitty terminal which is modified to
be very fast and Sleek because it's
always present as soon as you open Pi
search using a shortcut usually it will
be immediately there but it does more
than just search UI and retrieval you
can also execute all kinds of data you
save through that UI immediately
so
um then here's another demo
yes in this demo we basically show how
to
um
do a contribution to python search
itself using python search
we didn't want to run the demo here
because what basically be risky but
basically one is editing the file there
in the repo committing it creating a
pull request and visualizing the pull
request
using all entries that are already
registered in Python search
foreign
yes that's it so beyond that I just want
and as we talk about the type of data
that we have yeah we have three main
types of data first of data and form of
strings and urls
second python code that you can either
have as a code snippet or to execute it
directly from the terminal basically and
Bash code that can also be 10 bash
commands in a row being executed which
really helps automate all kinds of tasks
and we have many more than just those
three
thank you Inez with that said I will
just walk some through some other
features so we have an optional data
collection component so everything you
do will be recorded and we use that as a
data set to basically do some data
science on top so it's 100 local
so in the search and ranking space we
have a semantic search component and a
next item predictor that we'll try to
basically guess which entry you're gonna
need next so to make it really fast
uh we've been playing with some llms for
instance you can have like assistant
Android generation with uh GDP or others
every entry can have shortcuts and it
works on my and Linux
and we are working on a web app not sure
when that will get released though
uh yes with that said uh just a shout
out if you are interested in such a
thing
to get involved I mean we are looking
for developers practitioners designers
and you can learn a lot about you can
share about these topics basically
that's all
oh so thank you folks
thank you very much now comes Pai data
Amsterdam for two minutes and then we
have Johannes
tools through the python standard
Library
so you're already clipping so happily
now the next question you can answer by
clapping is what is your favorite text
editor and why is it Vima
okay emacs
Nano
Ed
then what we have vs code
pie charm
Notepad
[Applause]
Jupiter notebook
that's nice thank you
huh
anything else so anyone didn't clap
until now
[Applause]
uh Punch Cards
actually my favorite one was atom but it
was sunset
okay now we have by the entire Amsterdam
two minutes here we are
well thank you hello everyone my name is
Nikki phone number and I'm here today
with Sophie Vandenberg and we are both
from PI data Amsterdam and yesterday we
got inspired by one of the Talks by
Patrick of do y so we decided to create
our own
um
graph with a recommendation for you all
so if we want run this we get the
following so if you like Python and you
would like to sponsor open source we
recommend you to go to Pi data Amsterdam
if you like the community you met some
cool people you want to bring them to
Amsterdam come to buy data
if you like this conference and many for
many of you it was the first I heard in
the opening and you got inspired to give
a talk you can do so call for proposals
open soon
invited to Amsterdam
then I also heard many of you saying you
really like the food over here
in the Netherlands we have stroke
waffles so if you need an excuse
come to bareta Amsterdam
yeah so we're actually really really
excited to be able to share with you
that the buy that Amsterdam conference
this year will be held from the 14th to
16th of September
you guys are the first ones to hear this
actually it was only internally shared
so far yeah so if you'd like to attend
talk sponsor yeah we would love to see
all of you there or some of you the call
for proposals will be online next week
or the week after also tickets sales so
have a look at our website
we had our last conference in 2019 but
we will go a little bit bigger this year
so uh yeah really excited and uh hope to
see you there
thank you very much
you honest prepared
and the next one will be check with the
eu's proposed CRA law and why we care
yep
okay uh today we mark an anniversary
it's exactly 16 years since the release
of python 2.5.1
happy birthday
[Applause]
I did I started with python 2.5 yeah
that was a nice version it introduced a
width statement I think yeah
generators we had no F strings in those
oh well in those times we had plenty of
stuff that we didn't have at those times
and I would like to ask you who can tell
me it was not in the version 2.5 when
did python drop the support for curly
braces in the syntax
it can hurt some laughter
oh
so the answer is
never right okay Johan is prepared five
minutes stage is yours
hi I'm Johannes and I would like to give
you a talk uh and a tour through the
python standard library because python
comes famously with batteries included
and I think it's really useful to know
and really useful to remember some of
the gems that are in the standard
Library so
um here are a few of the gems that I
like especially the daytime module is
awesome it will help you stay sane for a
really long time until you descend into
madness
and you only have to know time Delta and
date time and perhaps time zone and that
will get you a very long way
um until it's too late the there are
collections
um especially useful are named tuples
which will help you uh to get your code
more readable if you use a lot of
toolbits default dicts um which will
instead of phrase and key Arrow they can
just return your default value and
counters which just make it really easy
to count the amount of stuff in a list
or and whatever
tools is really cool if your problem
feels like it's a combinatorics problem
then either tools is for you so whenever
the question is how many possibilities
are there to take so and so many with or
without Replacements this is what you
want
um there's the OS and the sub process
module which help you do stuff that you
would normally do in a shell so create
files move them around create
directories
run shell commands this can be done here
and the time it and C profile module
will help you find out how long your
code takes to do something they are
really easy to use and they are built in
so it's just a nice first step for
profiling
and then as turtle
well actually tell it's not something I
use on a daily basis but
but turtle is awesome for uh getting
beginners to uh to understand how uh
coding works and how python works and
actually
that is one of the most important things
we have in Python because not everybody
is doing data frames and machine
learning and stuff most of us have
started at some point
and it's in my opinion really important
to know and important to remember that
there is a part of python that is just
for the beginners
thank you
thank you very much
we have saved two minutes but we still
have a collection counter a lot of
proposals here now
trick then we will have Valerio with
python he brought some pizza and
pineapple pizza with pineapple Valerio
ah pineapple Ben
okay the next question
what is the airspeed velocity of an
unladen swallow
check
right
hello so um yeah we're having so much
fun in liking talk but I would like to
have a little bit of change of tone and
talk about something quite serious I who
have heard about cra
one
two three a few of them which is scary
because I'm here to tell you about what
is era and why we should care about it
who remember gdpr
or who remember the time before gdpr
where we were not asked like from all
the website that do we accept cookies
right so what I want to tell you is that
a lot of these kind of regulations and
law affect us every day especially
Developers
now we have this CRA so what it is
so what is CRA right it's something that
is happening in Europe it's a new act
that is proposed by the European Union
on
this if you want I will show you the
link later you can read the whole thing
but you know if you don't want to read
the whole thing I've seen a few of uh
the blogs that basically what the idea
is is to like put these labels so I I
guess now we're in Europe you have seen
this label everything like your you know
your your Appliance your toaster that
you bought from the you know from the
shop they all have this label which is
kind of like a guarantee of you know
certain standard has been fulfilled
right so it's safe to use that toaster
and now we are like the actors trying to
propose that we apply that to all the
software so it's safe to use
which is a good thing right but
but in open source things are a little
bit different right
who have seen this picture before yes
so a lot from open source project we all
know that it could be right just someone
started this project because they have a
problem to solve and they have solved
this problem but it's got like you know
so it got viral in today's term and
everybody was using it and they are
trying so hard just like one man then
trying to maintain it since like 2003
it's
we can't we can't ask them to kind of
demonstrate that these soft these small
piece of software which is open source
is compliance to the ACT and you know I
think maybe like you know they don't
have a time because they are maintaining
the project it's already very busy and
they do it like on a volunteer basis and
or if they ask another third party to do
it it will be quite expensive because
you have seen how complicated this thing
is right so
and um so in actually in the ACT if you
read all these like details there's
actually
certain thing I think it stay on like uh
article 10 or something like that that's
like saying that oh like a
non-commercial activities are extend it
so are we safe
well but what is a commercial activity
because now you know a lot of popular
open source project actually it won't be
so um easy to use or very like Smooth uh
without the support from some companies
or you know or some people donate to
them is it okay after this you know is
it kind of suddenly become commercial if
you you know sponsor your favorite
project
or you know if you know some company if
they develop these two they plan to open
source it maybe they would think twice
because well now I have to make it
compliance right so I maybe it would be
very expensive or you know even if you
are for example you work for a company
maybe your company suddenly decided that
oh we can't you know let you do open
source contribution because you know
it's again again you know become
commercial activity and we can't prove
that it's compliance and we can't use it
and you know very complicated things or
even some projects right they are backed
by a company that like the the funding
of their companies come from a cloud
service that they provide with that open
source software that they developed so
um yeah so there were there's actually a
lot of worries from the open source
Community about it and
I think more people should really know
about it and we should
actually get more informations and voice
our concerns
um they are already like a psf actually
posted a Blog about their concern and I
think we should read it and they have
some call for Action there as well
especially for python users in Europe so
please uh you know this is the most
important slice take a picture I will
also post this link on Discord for those
of you who may be watching it online
um so yeah also there's other blogs
other open source communities avoiding
out their concerns and that's the link
there the actual the CRA thing you can
if you have time if you want to read it
it's there so please take a picture of
this and look into these things so thank
you so much
thank you Chuck do we have Valerio for
two four minutes you need four minutes
okay you are two of them so we have four
minutes uh how much time do we have left
uh Alex
because are you going are we going to be
thrown out at a half past or yes
half past okay so we have like 10
minutes left
um okay so now let's clap a little bit
more what is your keyboard layout who is
using plain QWERTY ANSI keyboard layout
who is using the German or Austrian
convertz
erty
uh what's there at work
two or three separate keyboard Parts uh
with their custom layout
forgot anything uh QWERTY with compost
key
great anything else
Cantonese
so now we have some pizza and ananas
pineapple sorry
this is the only language where it is
here we are nice all right thank you
very much
um actually I have a quite bold
presentation here it's python Pizza in
the pineapple ban that's very serious
topic after what we listen to and and to
be honest that was actually inspired by
this sticker and now I have on my laptop
this was uh actually it's it's literally
a slice of pizza with a pineapple ban on
it so I started wondering well why
Italians hate pineapple pizza so much
that's Chad gbt for that but then he
told me I'm an AI language model I
didn't know anything about that so well
I can tell you for sure that's the
standard Italian reaction when you're a
pineapple pizza when it comes to
pineapple pizza actually you might
imagine something quite straightforward
though so what could possibly go wrong
when if you have a quick search you can
have pineapple pizza cake
you can have wrong pineapple pizza
still not edible you can have pineapple
pizza horror I think it's disgusting and
you have the inverse of pineapple pizza
it's actually
I don't know
What In All In All Seasons actually this
ticket was what brought me lots of good
memories and that was back in 2018 when
we had python Pie Pizza event in Naples
and uh I think it was the probably one
of the first not in Berlin that was
actually Naples and and it reminded me
that on in Python in Italy by the
Italian we have a Vibrant Community of
pythony's we have different sub
communities there pyroma parmilano
paitorino and python Pizza as well which
also brings me to remind you that
actually Pike in Italy is happening and
as you can see our Pagan D now is our
best and favorite conference
um we do have tons of keynot talks
trainings this year we have Jungle Girls
as usual but we also have Samantha
Christophe joining for a q a that's
super fantastic uh there's a schedule on
the website
um we have Alternatives and actually we
do together that's fine we have
alternatives to pineapple pizza
um way better I promise we have Garden
stage two social events and the
conference is going to be on from the
25th to 20 28th of May you can check out
the website and like dot it before
leaving I just reminded that I forgot to
tell you what is my favorite pizza and
in essence is the most simple you can
think of sliced tomato sauce mozzarella
and basil and if you by the way speaking
of Basil we do have a conference in
battle
that's a fantastic segue isn't it
you should see the next one
um so so we have you say hi and and to
be to be honest it's going to be uh 14
to 18 the August basil is the place of
guest and but we do have actually the
call for proposal that you're open now
and you can check out some pre-talks we
do accept different proposals or
different uh topics general purpose
python scientific application High
Performance Machine and deep learning
and so for you to slow point we do
actually have the cultural reversal open
but for Europe python actually it's
closed but now it's time for this my
segue sorry that's stupid yeah it's up
to you now
awesome yeah good but it's not there
you should see something yes
see it but yeah you'll see that yes uh
oh uh hi everyone so I'm here to talk
about yet another conference which is
happening right before the Euros iPod
but unfortunately the cfp is closed as
Valerie mentioned uh I'm here to talk
about Euro python who heard about Europe
python before
okay not everyone so europython is uh
another python conference it's big and
it's all that's been running for about
20 years and been traveling all over
Europe for that 20 some years the cfp is
closed but and we also had the community
voting and the reviews and that is also
closed as of right now so we're going to
publish a schedule soon
and
go to Europe I think that EU and
everything is over there
thank you
and the last one before because we have
to finish in five minutes Mark Andre I
forgot to introduce you but please you
do you have some time for us
would you come to stage
thank you thank you thank you now I have
a question yeah
in Berlin do you know
have your problem people you know
I think 2014 right
they were ice cream here okay I I don't
know about it because like I love ice
cream by the way if you don't know yet
um so yeah like europaizen please go and
check out the website I guess um so uh
any more questions for our yes we have
maybe one of the two last questions what
happens if you import anti-gravity in
Python
you fly but to you right because the
next talk yeah well so you have five
minutes here we are I can't wait thank
you
so you can see my slide
the question of the talk is is there or
will there be a future for power run how
many of you know pyron
that's what I thought
so um a bit about myself I think it was
already mentioned I'm one of the core
developers I also ran Europe python for
a couple of years
I was psf board member and lots of other
stuff I run a user group in Dusseldorf
so if you're interested off then please
consider attending
what is pyron so pyron is something that
we created a long long time ago in
nineteen end of 1990s
and it's been going on ever since then
what we wanted to do is we wanted to
have a very very small python
distribution
something that we can just ship out to
clients together with a product code and
then have them run it
so what we did is we took the C python
binary we added the complete or more or
less complete python standard library to
it
and we put everything into a single
binary
and you can then of course you know very
easily ship that binary around
uncompressed for python 3.10 it's just
16 megabytes compared to your normal
installation which is something like 200
megabytes
and if you compress it using upx
everyone knows upx right so it's a
compressor for binaries you can boil it
down to 5.2 megabytes which is really
tiny I mean it's basically the size of
an image
it can run more or less all the python
code we regularly use it internally as
well as a virtual engine replacement
it's very easy to ship around like I
said it's also great for container
images that need to be small
and it's open source it's Unix only
because we only use it on Unix but it
could potentially also be ported to
Windows
so let me see whether the demo gods are
with me
find my cursor there
so this is it
if you do a complete installation of
of Pi run then you also get some extra
files with it this is basically done to
be able to compile code
so you need to include you need the lip
directory
in here you can see the file sizes which
are really small
let me do this it's easier to read
so as you can see we have 60 megabyte
for pyron 3.10 if you want the debug
symbols included as well which you
normally don't then you have to pay some
extra
and the the upx one is 5.2 megabytes
and you can just take that file oops
that was the wrong one you can take that
file around
just copy it to a directory and let it
run
or anti-gravity I don't think this works
in a
in a show I don't know what this is but
um anyway you can see how it works right
or you just you know trust me that works
so
why am I presenting this well first of
all of course to to let you know that it
exists that you can actually get it
um but the main question there is
I want to know whether I should invest
more work into it because it's currently
it supports 3.6 until 3.10 and the work
to to make it happen with 3.11 is going
to be significant because there are so
many changes since 3.11 in the
underlying C API and also the internals
of how everything works during startup
it's going to be a lot of work so I just
want to ask you whether you're
interested in this
just you know clap
okay so that's like a fair amount I
don't know if I'm going to invest much
time into this
anyway thank you very much
so there are a few more left but it's
half past huh
it's half past six and we have
to finish but after uh python 2013 there
is certain 2023 there is certainly
python
future uh I would have a last question
very quick question how would you fix or
correct the phrase romanes and domus
because it's not correct Latin
correct but I am not going to send you
home because there is still
Alex is going to tell you certainly
social event
enjoy Berlin I thank you very much for
being here
and see you tomorrow at nine I think
nine nine
nine
oh yes
announcements are at nine
so how's your evening going to be all
settled
what's like I think I'm going to see the
social event a bit oh that's very good
so I can get you like really drunk
tonight you will still do a quick break
you know tomorrow let's see okay but
talking talking about the social
Gathering no no stay here please social
Gathering
um uh you can bring up the slides now
thank you social Gathering
um as you know we have the social
gathering tonight at the beef PCC it
requires a wristband one of these uh I
hope everybody here has gotten a ticket
and a wristband yeah show who has a
wristband
okay so you're all good
do you have a wristband
really I'm sure I will have one
thank you
well like yeah here you go so near is
also all set
um so please act responsibly uh we we
decided to have the social event here
tonight and uh we um we we just said
okay hand out wristband so please if you
don't have a wristband we were sorry if
you didn't get well if you weren't able
to get one we're really sorry we had to
limit a number also for the social event
even stuff it's really hard to get
nowadays so um so please if you haven't
act responsibly um see you tomorrow
morning but please don't hang around in
the building and we'll see you tomorrow
morning please act responsibility
responsibly and I really want to also
thank our sponsor who makes this happen
it's octopus energy they have a spoof
downstairs checked by they have really
cute pink octopuses and now I would
really say yeah enjoy the social
Gathering and thank you very much
[Applause]